agora
eu sou a lenda e vem aqui falar antes
sobre o que tem sido para mim a
experiência de fazer música é me que
lança na internet mais ou menos um
primeiro can que só como não sei onde
estou
em princípio o senhor não me conhece e
crie uma marca e uma em um personagem
online chamado filmado e se quer
praticar muito mais consciente por causa
do vídeo faz para o youtube criou um
canal do youtube em 2006 na altura
apenas como depósito crítica já fazia
antes
antes dera do da internet é e flecha a
única função do meu canal até 2008
quando participou agora participar num
passatempo cujo prêmio era um computador
isso em 2008 na 99 ipads na fonte
a gente ficava contente quando ganhava
uma talhadeira e um computador na
internet contendo filho meu primeiro
vídeo conclui pagar nenhum computador é
o meu primeiro vídeo já mas não diz fica
com a possibilidade do primeiro via
internet
mas os ares à canarinha deputado afirmou
que queria muito fazer por outro lado
foi poeta em um carro chegaram a cortar
sempre tarde e não chegou ao city em
2009 e 12 de inscritos como foram dando
confiança continentais o git em 2009
finalmente tive meu primeiro vídeo viral
foi o segundo desde que eles tivessem
sido feitas a sul e do oeste mãos do
juiz - e vai ser feito nos a surgir
neste vídeo você sabe né sem o conceito
e não parece a minha cara é fácil brajá
leste alguns filhos mas este tema
conclusão em três que é o sucesso de
mais 20 está intimamente ligado ao fato
da minha casa não conseguia eles
esse produto é uma confiança renovada
pelo feed backs vendas pessoas feridas
antes de ter matado mais alta confiança
fazendo 20 cada vez mais exatos pra mim
é em finalmente hoje em dia
já seu parceiro do itu o primeiro
português já tem parceria com o conflito
tem cerca de 230 vídeo no canal
no total os meus vídeos passaram a 7
milhões de visualizações tem cerca de 25
mil escrituras sony itho e nas redes
sociais de mensagens têm cerca de 29 mil
seguidores
dito isso aqui é que tenha sido para mim
a experiência de fazer comédia online ea
michelin desde 27 de trabalho é fácil o
trabalho que fazia e foi por isso que
distingue por fazer vídeos e sons
a marca da nossa província acerca da mas
com que fiquei é que o jogo no
continente por exemplo com devia falar
do sul haviam nas notícias surgem
histórias com os jovens da diáspora
conheciam as histórias com os pais deles
e os km e descontavam por isso na cabeça
alguns deles é visualizavam um pulso da
palavra
tão certa mas era preciso mas o milan
queria e quando falavam os avanços o que
eles visualizavam harmattan tocadas otan
suas tristes afirmar e ontem ciclone
outra coisa com surpreender talvez ainda
mais chiques foi a reação do dos
açorianos em particular da juventude
açoriana recebeu os meus 20 com muitos a
sensação com que fiquei comentários são
feitos com muitos deles está muito atrás
da gente é ser convidado pela muitas
escolas através da conversa de surdos
com o pai já que tem 17 de algo sobre a
sua tarefa
não fui à imagem mas saudada imigração a
bruma e os xailes negros dessas coisas
assim
um rapaz de 10 anos ganhamos do estado
buscam dar a volta e 21 11
junte a dizer coisas como a pistola
hoje em dia os mais jovens um canal no
youtube quer sejam bem quer seja do
profissional que é
porém eles têm exatamente a mesma imagem
portão 5 do que o canal na visão do
jovem hoje em dia o canal é filmado um
exemplo para ele o canal estimado tentam
tempo tóxico na tv
o conceito faz confusão amo mas pra ele
hoje em dia é é simples nós podemos
desprezar então sei que tem um canal um
vídeo no youtube
mas quando eram abordadas nas escolas
ainda na rua velhos às vezes era tirar
um novo e tem operações com deixavam às
vezes constrange por ficar oito dias
simples ficava nervoso e até 25 um rapaz
de 15 anos que andava de um lado a outro
bulls que não acreditava que existia uma
estrela estrela do vídeo no segundo
tempo
da internet pra ele é com uma pessoa com
pra mim era uma pessoa conhecida na
televisão e em buriti cada vez mais para
essa reação das nossas sons não se
deseja as nossas tradições do século 21
continua a trabalhar a imagem ser mesmo
uma perspectiva michaela sobre o assunto
é falso à polícia que ela ia apresentar
uma perspectiva de frente
olha só a e oe exemplo disso a e o o os
entes não são sempre iguais também
sempre dá importância à universalidade
dos temas nos 20 a minha parte do sul do
continente brasil dimensão simplesmente
porque existem dois lados do campo e é
sempre importante na minha preocupação é
fazer o ouvinte e não faça a sobre o
tema é tão específico como a revista
realidade das bandas filarmônicas de
existência
ganhamos então tento fazer nesse caso e
fez um vídeo sobre o que não fazer num
encontro romântico mas como não gostar
da gente para cima da mesa no qual então
entre os sons por exemplo mas num tema
que é facilmente identificável por uma
pessoa por isso é esta é a forma que eu
encontrei do sul e trazê-las à baila
infelizmente a gente não sou o único
nesse esforço de surgir
infelizmente hoje em dia se inscreverem
a surgir no estribo existem imensos
canais e semestre de 2011
com isso a maior parte nós já essa
ferramenta divino cardoso rafael mas sim
mas eu também então um canal no youtube
sigo o site dele
infelizmente hoje em dia existem páginas
no facebook dedicadas ou o ano e é com
orgulho que disse que hoje em dia seus
famosos mostrando na net
obrigado